give a nice introduction so
i'm going to talk about fast
satisfiability algorithms for systems of
polynomial equations over finite fields
and i skip this part
so we consider systems of polynomial
equations
and
these have been studied
for more than 300 years
actually
resultant and elimination theory were
used by
seki and bezu
in the 18th century
so the problem has a long history
and
we consider the problem called syspolix
q
which is systems of polynomial equations
over gfq
and
our input is
jsq polynomials p1p2 through pm in
formal variables x1 x2 x
3xn
like this
so here q is three and p one is like
this and p two is like this
and
our task is to find a satisfying
assignment a that is an assignment that
makes
all the polynomials zero
and in this case this assignment
satisfies all the polynomials
as you can see
and
this number 64xq
denotes the counting version of the
problem so we have to count the number
of satisfying assignments
okay
and what is known about the complexity
of this body xq
the problem is in p if each polynomial
has degree at most one by gaussian
elimination
and the problem is np complete
if each polynomial has
degree at most two
and in addition
satisfying uh this
fraction of equations
is np had
on satisfiable instances
even
when actually when q is 2
and degree is at the most d
and
the current
best last k super bound is
trivial 1 q to the n times
40 of input size
and
this is even if q is 2
and degrees at the most 2.
so
this problem looks
extremely hard
and
so
this problem
is used as hardness assumption
in cryptography
and there are several cryptosystems
assuming the hardness of
enumerating all satisfying assignments
such as
hfe
uob or macro alias variance polica i
don't know the details of this but
also there are several crypto systems
assuming the hardness of
finding a single satisfying assignment
such as quad or mass motor in my public
key scheme and so on
okay
and
the hardness of this problem is also
used in fine-grained complexity
so
strong exponential time hypothesis
that q to the n is necessary
for
this body skew on degree 2
instances implies this that is
the current best algorithm for the
listing triangle
problem is
optimal and
getting brute force for the
gfq weighted ok click problem is
impossible
so
the problem
is has been believed to
be very hard
and
there are several previous algorithms
the most famous one is
graven basis
which is widely used in practice
but
runs
in doubly exponential time
in the worst case
and um
two thousand times one minus epsilon or
polynomial time algorithms
for uh syspolix two
on degree two instances are known if
instances satisfy some
conditions some algebraic conditions
and
there's also
a
result about unsatisfiability
so
puts
showed that there exists a q to the n
over two thanks blue
for the
unsatisfiability
of this polyexecute on degraded
instances
this means
there's a
co-non-deterministic algorithm for
the satisfiability of
these instances
okay
and
this is our result one
we showed
this politics q
on degree k
instances can be solved in
randomized time
q to the n times 1 minus 1 over order q
qk
and in particular for
q and kr2
this is an important case for
cryptography
we get the bound of
0.868765
n
so this is uh
to the best of our knowledge the first
non-trivial upper bound for the problem
and this is our second result
here
q should be
a prime number
and in this case
uh we show a number this politics q
on degree k instances can be solved in
uh deterministic time q to the n times
one minus one over order q k
so
the points here
are deterministic on the counting
and
prime
field and this is a versatile result
here
we consider
unbounded degree polynomials
but we have to focus on gf2
and
let s be the total number of monomers
then
the number systemics 2 can be solved
during
deterministic time 2 to z n times 1
minus 1 over o log s over n
and
this
running time is
exponentially faster than 2 to the n if
s is odyn
and this is our fourth result
here we consider
more
general
problem
so we consider
so called
sigma pi sigma circuits
that is a sum of products of linear
forms
like this so each polynomial
is
represented as the sum
products of product of linear forms
okay
and
again we show that
if s is the total number of products of
linear forms then
this problem can be solved in
deterministic time
like this
this is
the same expression
in the previous
method
and
so
we show
this is exponentially faster than to
then if s is odyn
and i would like to remark that um
casey neistat
is a special case of sysbolics two
on
degree k instances
so
you can see uh
these three clauses
can be represented as polynomials
and the condition that these clauses are
satisfied
is equivalent to the conditions these
polynomials
simultaneously deal
and
this
connection
explains
the
optimality of our results
so
we show uh
sysforex2 this foreign
time
of this form and the
it is known
that kcnf sat can be solved during time
due to the
n times 1 minus 1 over k
so if we
would like to improve the dependency on
k
uh
k here we must improve
uh the upper bound for k c and f
okay
and
so this result
here we consider uh
sigma pi sigma circuit
and s is the total number of products of
linear forms
and
we get the running time of the form like
this and
as for
cnf that
if we
set s is the number of
clauses then
it is known that cnf sat can be solved
during time 2 to the n times 1 minus 1
over 2 log
s over n
so
again
if we would like to improve this part
then
we also have to improve this part for
cnf thought
and
this is
a summary of our techniques
so our
algorithm is based on the so-called
polynomial method in circuit complexity
which is originally used for
probing circuit side lower bounds
and
we use
extensions of
fast
evaluation algorithms for polynomials
due to yields and other peoples
and
approximation polynomials by low degree
probabilistic polynomials due to algebra
and the smallest key and it's
the randomization about version due to
chang and the idioms
and
we also use extensions of
so-called shiraz with this reduction for
cnf thought
okay
so
what is the polynomial method
recall that an
ac 0q circuit
is a
bounded dips unbounded fine boolean
circuit with end or
not
and modular queue gates
and
razer bluff and the smallest key
showed the following circuit robons
so they showed first um
hg0q circuit can be
well approximated by a low degree gfq
polynomial
and second they showed
majority and modular r functions can't
be
well approximated by a low degree gfq
polynomial
so combining these two
and they showed these majority and the
modulo are functions can't be computed
by ac 0q circuits
and
it turns out
that
this item 1
is
useful in algorithm design
and actually we use it
okay
so let me
briefly explain
our algorithms by a polynomial method
okay and in what world we focus on gs2
this is our tool number one
um
here let p
be
gs2 polynomial
represented as a sum of monomials
then
the truth table of b
can be generated in time for u of n
times 2 to the n
and this result is non-trivial because
the number of monomials in p
can be
2 to the n so
if
we evaluate p of x for
each x
then
it takes
poly of n times 4 to the n
this is the basic idea of our algorithm
our input
is degree k polynomials
and we define a polynomial p
as
a
product of
p1 plus one
through pm plus one
then
you can see
all of these polynomials
there if and only
p of x is one
and you can also see that
p might contain two to the number of
monomials
when
it is
represented as a sum of monomials
because
this
is
a degree in
polynomial
next we define
a function r as a product of
p of y a plus 1
over
all
assignment a
in 0 1 to the n prime for some
appropriately chosen in a prime
and
then
you can see
that
there exists some x such that p of x is
one
in front only
there exists some y such that r of y is
zero
and here
each
polynomial b
y a
might contain
2 to the n minus n prime monomials
but
for now we
ignore these
numbers then
we can
observe that um
if we can write
this
alloy function
as a sum of monomials in time 2 to the n
minus n prime
then
we can also solve the
problem in time value of n times 2 to
the n minus n prime
by using the first evaluation lemma
because this function is a polynomial in
n minus any prime variables
but
unfortunately
if we
expansion this roi
into a sum of
monomials into
a straightforward mammal then it might
take
time to the end
so
we need some
additional idea
and
this is our to number two
and let me define some function q
for
s1 through sd
and
z1 to the n
we define
degree d polynomial q
as
this and
here
this
this bracket means
the inner product
of s i and x
and
our intuition is um
this
q
function
approximates
a product
of x y plus 1 over
i n
and actually
that's both and the smallest key
shows that if we select random s1
through sd
uniformly and independently
then
for every non-zero x
the probability that
q of x is zero
is one over minus two to the minus
so if we set d
substituently large then
uh this
q function
approximates uh this product
with high probability
and
it is easy to see that
q of zero is always one
and
now i can explain our algorithm for
degree k instances
so we define
p
and r as before
and then
we
replace each product
so
a
product like this or product
here
by a probabilistic polynomial and
write
this r as a sum of monomials b
and then
we construct the true of
t of p
using the first evaluation algorithm
and if
t contains an entry with zero then
the input has a solution
and to reduce the error probability we
repeat
steps 3 and 4
sufficiently many times and
take the majority voting of
many t's
okay
and
to
analyze
the running time the most important part
is here
but
this step
takes only time for u of n times 2 to
the n minus n prime for appropriately
chosen
the prime if
we replace
each product
by a sufficiently low degree polynomial
i don't show the calculation but
this is
enough to get the bond here
okay
so
from this algorithm we get
a result one
and
to the randomize this algorithm
we need some
additional ideas so
um
first we use
uh the randomization probabilistic
polynomial due to
uh zebra and the smallest key by chand
williams
and
their
idea is
based on
so-called small biased space
and
modulus amplifying polynomial
we also use
some fast evaluation algorithms for
non-multi-linear integer polynomials
and this algorithm is based on
the first
rectangular matrix multiplication
but
i skip the details of these
and
now i would like to explain our
algorithm for unbounded degree instances
and here
we
introduce
some procedure called degree reduction
and this procedure generates
exponentially many instances of syspolix
such that
the original input has a solution
if and only at least one of generated
instances has a solution
and
second
all generated instances have degree at
most okay
so now we can apply the algorithm for
degree gaining instances
and what
we do
in degree deduction it's a
fairly simple idea
so
while there is a monomial degree
more than k
such as a
product of x one through x n
and then
we
generate
two instances
i1 and i2
by setting uh this
x1 through xk product of x13xk
is one
or zero
and
in the first case
this implies
this
and in the second instance
we just add this
as a
new polynomial equation
and
in general
we can extend this
procedure
for
sigma pi sigma circuits by using some
simplification rules based on change of
basis
but
i will skip this part
okay
so let me conclude
these are our results
first we showed
that this particular on degree k
instances can be solved with
randomize the time of this
and
if q is a prime number
we get a
deterministic algorithm for the counting
version of the problem
and
if
q is 2
then we can
handle more general problems so
each polynomial has unbounded degree and
actually each monomial is a product of
linear
forms okay
and these results are in some sense
optimal
because
improvement requires that for
cnf sat on the kcnf that
there are several interesting future
directions
so
first we
would like to obtain similar running
time in
polynomial space because our algorithm
uses exponential space and
for applications it's not desirable
and
we can only show that degree reduction
works for
uh
the case q is 2 so
we would like to extend this to
the k squared not equal to
also we
would like to
beat
root for such algorithm for other
problems using the polynomial method
and
the last one is
to develop or apply
first evaluation algorithms for more
expressive classes
some polynomials such as
constant deep circuits or formula
and
obtain some
new
interesting algorithms
and that's all i have to say thank you
thank you very much
very heavy machinery questions comments
right
uh can you
what would be your target class like how
would you generalize polynomials
like
what do you expect the next fast
evaluation algorithm to be about
uh actually there are some results about
dips to
symmetric circuits or threshold circuits
so maybe you can apply them
for some related problems
on one of your first slides you have
polycracker crypto system
and i was curious
how
i've noticed more and more references to
that i just wondered how
if you see it it's becoming more and
more important the reason i'm curious is
because mike was and neil kobletts were
the
originators of polycracker so it's
always been in the back of my mind
i don't know the details but yeah
it's nice to know
okay then let's thank the speaker again